[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro 2 si on rentrait quatrième rendez
vous ce soir que nous vous proposons
pour vous accompagner en cette période
qui reste difficile comment vous occupez
en toute sécurité chez vous et
aujourd'hui nous parlerons de méditation
en pleine conscience l'une de nos
journalistes s'est livré à l'exercice
est ce vraiment efficace pour se relaxer
pour maintenir le lien avec leurs
adhérents les associations proposent
toujours des cours en ligne et des
séances qui peuvent se pratiquer
maintenant donc en famille à la maison
et puis comment réussir un bon brunch ce
week end conseils à suivre pour profiter
pleinement de votre dimanche matin
[Musique]
et pour débuter nous allons donc nous
relaxer célia bonjour et bienvenue sur
ce plateau
vous avez testé la méditation de pleine
conscience c'est une méditation alors je
lis mes fiches dans ancré dans l'instant
présent si j'ai bien compris c'est ça
c'est exactement ça alors moi c'était
aussi une première pour moi j'ai
rencontré agnès cordonnier ici gagnant
elle est au thérapeute et coach de vie
alors au début de la séance surprise
elle me demande de marcher dans la pièce
puis de lever les bras au rythme de ma
respiration
ensuite je devais à tapoter tout mon
corps pour faire circuler les énergies
tout ça c'est très relaxant on s'assoit
un petit peu quand même
we will be you passoire en fait on a
commencé à faire des exercices de
respiration ventrale et puis je devais
être attentives aux appris de mon corps
visualisez vos mollets
vous de bien déposer au sol
la méditation de pleine conscience est
une exploration dans ses sensations
corporelles
j'ai mis en éveil mes cinq sens je vous
invite à accueillir tous les bruits
environnants et les bruits que vous
pouvez percevoir de votre corps pour
mettre en éveil
votre sens de louer la la méditation
permet aussi de s'évader tout en restant
connecté à l'instant présent que vous
traversez une forêt là maintenant une
forêt aux feuilles jaunes et pourpre
à ce moment là on est entre l'évêque et
le sommeil un peu la fin de la séance on
se réactive on se réveille un peu oui
c'est ça en fait agnès m'a demandé de
progressivement augmenter mon rythme
respiratoire secoué ma tête et mes tirs
et la séance c'est une demi heure
comment on se sent à l'issue de cette
séance et ce à tout l'intérêt c'est ça
qu'on veut savoir
eh bien on se sent bien on se sent très
bien moi qui est de nature un peu
stressé j'étais plutôt détendue et
apaisée
alors au niveau du temps j'ai fait une
séance d'une demi heure mais on peut
très bien faire une séance d'un quart
d'heure ou d'une heure vraiment le tout
c'est d'être d'être constant pour que ça
marche
voilà être régulier sur sur l'exercice
mais en tout cas vous êtes un peu plus
détendu pour cette fin d'année 2020 est
effectivement en ce moment plutôt une
bonne nouvelle
merci célia en tout cas bien que le
déconfinement soit donc annoncer si vous
avez suivi les annonces encore encore
aujourd'hui du premier ministre les
associations culturelles et même
sportives vont sans doute encore avoir
besoin de la visioconférence exemple
dans les yvelines avec la compagnie de
théâtre 7 septembre et puis le rugby
club de versailles lui aussi propose des
activités à ses adhérents en ligne skype
et zoom ou encore google mythe
les associations yvelinoise se sont
mises à la visioconférence
un outil qui leur permet de maintenir
une activité pendant ce deuxième
confinement pour le rugby club de
versailles les cours en visio se
concentre sur la préparation physique on
est en général entre 40 et 50
donc les mecs viennent à 19h sur le sur
le zoom on utilise zoom comme comme
appli et puis et puis après je leur
donne tout ce qu'ils ont à faire
je leur explique ça ça dure entre 45
minutes et une heure et puis les mecs
les mecs en bavent pourquoi côté culture
la compagnie du 7 septembre
elle aussi a choisi ce format au
programme rencontres répétition et
exercices de diction
là par exemple ils se sont aussi
déconnecté tous ils se sont téléphonés
par bin et ils ont écrit des petits
textes ensemble après il se reconnecte
et je lui ai mis à la caméra deux par
deux et 10 leur texte après je leur
propose des intentions de jeu
il les joue parc donc voilà ça ça peut
être un exercice
une autre manière de travailler plus axé
sur la préparation et la technique
un format qui permet d'organiser
et la reprise mais qui ne remplacent pas
les séances en présentiel
le théâtre c'est quand même un art qui
est vivant donc forcément c'est un peu
bizarre mais ça se passe plutôt bien
parce qu'on puisse qu'on travaille
vraiment des exercices et qu'on
approfondit beaucoup en fait on a
vraiment l'impression de faire un vrai
cours de théâtre
rien ne remplacera jamais le ballon
c'est bien pour l'entraînement
l'entraînement collectif au jeu de rugby
mais ça maintient les ça maintient les
joueurs en condition physique de manière
à préparer la reprise qu'on espère la
plus rapide possible
et puis ça on va dire que ça contribue
quand même malgré tout au bien être
pendant le confinement selon les
annonces gouvernementales ce mardi 24
novembre
les activités pour y reprendre pour tous
courant janvier et nous ouvrons une page
culinaire à présent dans cette émission
si on rentrait miquel et demi d'euros
amateurs de bonnes choses nous a rejoint
bonjour mickey un jour vous allez nous
expliquer comment préparer un brunch à
la maison alors petite définition
peut-être pour commencer d'où vient ce
mot qu'est ce que ça signifie c'est quoi
un brunch alors un brunch est un repas
qui se prend généralement entre la fin
de matinée le début de l'après midi
vous l'aurez compris c'est plutôt
conseillé pour les lève tard wilfried
alors très à la mode chez les pays anglo
saxons le dimanche
il combine à la fois des plats salés des
viennoiseries les boissons chaudes
généralement c'est très copieux wilfried
lydia bel hadid co gérante d'un
restaurant situé à versailles avec sa
soeur karim a proposé brunch maison à
nous présente les ingrédients
indispensables pour un bon proche des
pancakes des oeufs brouillés le jus
d'orange pressé
[Musique]
un petit peu de chantilly pour
accompagner les pancakes 1a page avec un
petit plat avec une petite salade de
fruits en dessert éventuellement aussi
un granola est très apprécié par nos
clients
c'est diététique tout de même oui on
peut le dire s'est dit éthique et
surtout ça donne très envie hein comme
vous avez pu le voir c'est très rapide à
cuisiner en général à un brunch se
prépare en 20 minutes montre en main le
plus long à préparer c'est peut-être les
tartines garni il faut préparer le
guacamole avec un avocat des tomates
cerises du sel et du citron jaune ou
vert les oignons sont facultatifs
ensuite il faut dorer les tartines pour
le premier toast il faut du fromage
frais et le guacamole pour le second il
faut lui de satie qui est du saumon
c'est très coloré ça plaira à toute la
famille à notre plat à préparer
absolument lors d'un brunch les pancakes
maison lydia nous donne sa recette
vous pouvez partir c'est par exemple 2e
avec après 60 g de sucre pour mélange
ensuite vous ajouter je vais dire un
quart d'un livre de l'est voilà avec 200
g de farine 1 sachet de levure et on
mélange le tout et c'est parti et il ya
bien sûr les indispensables boissons
chaudes c'est un indispensable je disais
sans boisson chaude il n'y a pas de
brunchs sont certains aficionados
boisson chaude à voir la photo de
chocolat chaud par exemple le chocolat
chaud alors pareil en ont fait maison
parce que c'est vraiment meilleur voilà
du lait du vrai chocolat noir avec une
petite touche de crème c'est parfait
après pour les plus gourmands vous
veillez ajouta un petit peu de caramel
un petit peu de nutella pour pour
relever un peu plus votre chocolat on
est bien calé pour la journée ensuite un
coup néanmoins oui alors dans cet
établissement versailles et il faudra
débourser 25 euros pour un brunch pour
plus d'information vous pouvez aller sur
les réseaux sociaux du restaurant puis
aussi on peut le préparer à la maison
bien évidemment et j'imagine michael que
si votre femme a regardé ça ce week-end
vous êtes bon pour lui préparer un
samedi
dimanche samedi où 10 matches c'est un
lieu dimanche vous serez en cuisine pour
faire le brunch si on va continuer à
parler cuisine dans un instant après une
petite pause littérature tout de même
nous n'irons pas ou anne c'est le titre
du nouveau livre de philippe gust qui
sortira en décembre bientôt cet auteur
évinois appris la situation actuelle
comme point de départ comme toile de
fond de son aventure qui débute à
versailles mais aussi à saint germain en
laye on les écoute il y avait un truc
qui ce qui c'est qui se superposent et
dans le vivre l'une qui concerne le
laboratoire de luan et puis l'autre qui
porte sur l'intelligence artificielle
est quelque chose qui a été fait par le
google était diffusée par le financial
times et qui était tout de suite retirée
des médias à la demande de google
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y à un certain nombre de blockhaus
qui ont été construits par les allemands
est la 2e durant la seconde guerre
mondiale et il y en a un qui est énorme
qui fait plus de casse mais 500 m² qui
est une véritable américain immeuble
souterrain et une partie de l'intrigué
se passe dans cet immeuble où a été
installé une salle de contrôle du fameux
ordinateur
gérard l'intelligence artificielle de
deux quelque chose que l'on peut
découvrir dans le vivant ça un bon roman
d'aventuré il est à dire que
effectivement si le sujet est triste un
petit peu le comité c'est quelque chose
qui est triste mort là on est au nepad
ans à se lamenter
on est en train de se balader dans le
monde à découvrir des gens
[Musique]
et après le mode d'emploi du brunch
parfait il ya quelques instants nous
passons une application plein de bons
conseils culinaires bonjour justin
l'application s'appelle à pettitte à
elle a été créé par un ingénieur agro
alimentaires originaires des bouquets il
promeut bien évidemment la cuisine fait
maison
exactement alors est ce que vous êtes
déjà demandé en ouvrant votre frigo
qu'est ce que je vais manger ce soir
tous les jours et bien voilà il ya
l'application est fait pour vous c'est
un dépanneur à d'idées de recettes
elle en propose plus de 1000 tout testé
par ap tia est vue avec des chefs et des
diététiciens
on s'est rendu compte c'est que les gens
de cuisiner c'est ne cuisinent et pas
assez parce qu'ils manquent et dj au
quotidien il manquait d'idées il
manquait de temps et donc du coup on
s'est vraiment concentré sur ce problème
le manque d'idées et du coup on a voulu
créer cette application qui est du coup
un algorithme de recommandations de
recettes qui prend en compte du coup
toutes les contraintes que des personnes
vont avoir et qui vont être
déterminantes dans l'eure dans leur
envie de cuisiner et comment ça
fonctionne et c'est simple c'est ça
exactement en avril c'est ça aussi c'est
pratique
vous ouvrez l'application elle est
disponible sur apple et android
et là vous créez un compte il faut
répondre à quelques questions selon vos
envies notamment quels types de recettes
vous souhaitez est ce que c'est pour une
entrée un plat ou un dessert quel est
votre envie express convivial pour
combien de personnes vont cuisiner on
s'adapte à tout même à votre matériel et
à vos compétences est ce que vous savez
cuisine et du chou fleur ou encore
dépendre des termes pas être et 2,6 et
moitié sert à quoi ce questionnaire et
bien en fait c'est parce que
l'application cherche à encourager les
personnes à cuisiner au quotidien avec
une alimentation plus saine et donc elle
s'adresse aux personnes qui aimeraient
se lancer mais qui ne savent pas comment
faire et donc le but c'est de ces
questions c'est de s'adapter et
d'accompagner ces personnes en leur
proposant des recettes sur mesure avoir
une recette scène c'est bien mais si
elle nous donne pas envie si on peut pas
la faire parce qu'on n'a pas de course
il peut pas la faire parce qu'on n'a
jamais cuisiné des épinards et qu'on n'a
pas du tout le temps d'apprendre la
technique etc
en fait on va pas la cuisine et donc ça
sert à rien fait donc c'est vraiment
une application pour le sur mesure c'est
ça aide les personnes à passer à
l'action et du coup à savoir comment
mange sainement et pouvoir le faire
réellement en fait dans leur cuisine
l'application est gratuite il y aura une
fonctionnalité nutrition qui va être
mise à jour vous pourrez faire attention
notamment à tout ce qui est allergies ou
encore cholestérol et puis cette
nouveauté donc sera accessible dans les
prochains jours via par contre cette
fois un abonnement premium
voilà pour cette émission très culinaire
aujourd'hui pour ce nouveau numéro 2 si
on rentrait merci beaucoup justin numéro
donc qui s'achève on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine et bien que le des
confirmands s'annonce prenez bien soin
de vous à bientôt
[Musique]